[Music]
on this thursday night records shattered
in canada's coveted hot spots
are tighter restrictions coming plus the
drastic measures
in one ontario region this is life and
death
bc's covet hospitalizations hit an
all-time high
and in alberta more students move to
online learning
a big shift the federal conservative
leader puts a price on carbon
it is not a tax it's a tax
and heartbreaking memories and searing
grief
we are reliving the
immediate pain that we felt how nova
scotians are coping a year after
a mass killing
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
the worst predictions about covet ones
we've been reporting on since early
january
are now playing out in parts of canada
the third wave is driving up case counts
higher than they have ever been
national daily case counts are rising
steeply exceeding the first and second
waves and
these numbers reflect transmission from
two weeks ago canada's top doctor says
things may get worse before they get
better
ontario bc and alberta are leading the
way there is talk in all of them of
tighter restrictions
ontario is considering a province-wide
curfew
here is why more than 4700 new cases
were reported in ontario today it has
never been that high
and people are dying in greater numbers
29 deaths reported today
659 people are in icu and that is more
than ever before
premier doug ford's cabinet is debating
imposing tighter restrictions
potentially at curfew and there is
growing consensus something
has to be done things are not going to
get better
if if we don't change what we're doing
things will in fact get worse
the situation in one part of ontario is
already
spiraling out of control the health unit
in gray bruce that's northwest of
toronto
is warning every resident there to
consider themselves a covid 19 carrier
and telling them to stay home for the
next 48 hours
kamil karamali has our top story tonight
few pedestrians even fewer cars
this is what it looks like when a
region's number of coven 19 cases
surges past its breaking point total
shutdown
i think this has sort of re-let the the
fear
and got people thinking about it the
gray bruce public health unit just a
couple of hours northwest of toronto
usually sees fewer than 10 new covet 19
cases a day
but now it's hit more than 70 new cases
in just 36 hours leaving residents and
local business owners
worried we're absolutely terrified that
our employees are going to
get sick and in fact their loved ones
the public health unit says the source
of the rapid transmission
is residents not following lockdown
rules
people visiting other homes social
gatherings
and so-called bush parties held by high
school students
what's made matters worse people lying
when they're asked about contact tracing
which is why the surgeon cases caught
everyone so off guard
please if you get contacted by the
health unit be honest with them
about who you've been with where you've
been don't try and hide it from yourself
or your parents
the public health unit is now asking all
160
000 people under its care to consider
themselves a coveted 19 carrier
for the next two days until they can
reach all the cases and contacts
on their list that's nearly 500 people
there are two situations or two clusters
in a community
related to younger people partying after
uh
hours not related to the school per se
and and that really generates many cases
kamil karamali global news toronto in bc
more people than ever before
are in intensive care now and case
counts keep rising
the idea of new restrictions is being
floated there too
the province recorded more than 1200 new
cases today driven by
infections in younger people new
modeling shows case numbers of increase
nearly across nearly all age groups
particularly in age 19 to 39 year olds
shown in green on this graph and 40 to
59 year olds shown
in the red line this is a different game
right now
the restrictions this concept that we're
in the
end game and and we can let things go we
can make exceptions for ourselves
are things that we all need to pay
attention to again
the end is coming but we're not there
yet
and we're going to see the impact
tragically on the people we're closest
to
if we don't pay attention to it now
global bc's legislative bureau chief
keith baldry is with me from victoria
keith younger people getting sick in bc
health officials though still saying
schools aren't a big factor
are more restrictions likely then yeah
interestingly enough today donna we
were given some new data from studies of
metro vancouver schools showing that by
and large schools are not where
the virus is being transmitted it's
being picked up in the community and
then occasionally brought into school
but schools aren't going to close and
the presentation made it very clear
today why that's going to be also
interestingly today
dr henry reminding us of her three
guiding principles in this pandemic
number one was keeping the number of
people dying at
as low a number as possible we are
succeeding to a large degree on that we
have one of the the lowest
per capita death mortality rates west
virginia brunswick
secondly we've prevented our health care
system from being overwhelmed by cold
bit even though we have a record number
of hospitalizations in icu's
uh they have yet to overwhelm the system
and finally and she reminded
me of us of this and this goes to
restrictions she says she wants minimal
disruptions to society
that's why bc's never had the level of
restrictions we see in ontario
and quebec and that's one big reason why
i don't think we're going to have much
more restrictions than what we currently
have
here in british columbia all right keith
baldry and victoria thank you
well alberta still leads the country in
the number of active cases per capita
infection levels are so high among
school-aged kids that calgary's two
largest school boards have decided all
classes
from grades seven to 12 will move online
on monday for at least two weeks
the premier has added more restrictions
as case counts continue to rise
heather urix west reports
for carolyn chin hearing that her two
high school aged kids would be returning
to virtual learning
came as a relief if you consider it in
high school
there's no way you can maintain social
distance in two meters
starting monday all junior high and high
schools in calgary's two largest school
districts
will move online for two weeks the
calgary board of education has more than
6 000 students and staff in isolation
what has happened is that since march
coming back after
the spring break we've seen a
significant
increase in positive cases in our
schools the number of cases per capita
is rising quickly among school-aged
children
and is now higher than its previous peak
in early december
the age group now has among the highest
number of active cases
second only to albertans aged 20-29
although transmission is happening in
the schools much of the virus is also
being acquired in the community
it's why alberta health is now also
requiring that all youth sports and
performance activities in calgary
either pause for two weeks or move
outside
i would ask that all parents and
students continue making safe choices
and remember that social activities
outside of school can easily
spread the virus and put schools at risk
with daily case counts on the rise dr
dina hinshaw says
further restrictions may be required
soon to protect the province's health
system from becoming overwhelmed
we're seeing more commonly now than we
saw in the first two waves
uh are patients that um are younger you
know in their 20s
30s 40s um that don't really have any
health problems they're coming in
um healthy with severe covet ending up
fighting for their life on a ventilator
this week alberta health said the
youngest patient in intensive care
was just 15 years old heather urex west
global news
calgary the capital of nunavut is now
under strict lockdown after confirming
its first case of covid19 since the
pandemic began
all schools non-essential businesses and
government offices in iqaluit are closed
residents are being urged to stay home
and limit contact with people outside
their households masks are now mandatory
none of its main airline canadian north
says the infected individual is one of
its employees and that contact tracing
is underway
a public health emergency in nunavut was
extended today until
april 29th well vaccines can't roll out
fast enough to protect canadians and
today there's news
of another delay the military commander
leading vaccine logistics in canada says
1.2 million doses
of the moderna vaccine that was
scheduled to arrive next week
won't get here until the end of april or
possibly
the first week of may
we're fully aware the provinces are
making adjustments
and we're trying to narrow this down as
much as possible so that they don't
find themselves in a situation where
they have to constantly react
to perceived delays
he says 855 000 moderna doses that were
supposed to arrive last week arrived
earlier this week
forte also says ottawa is working
closely with moderna which has agreed to
narrow its delivery cycle to canada from
three weeks
to two weeks the conservatives have a
climate policy coming up what aaron
o'toole revealed today
about putting a price on carbon
the political divide in canada over
carbon pricing got a bit smaller today
conservative leader aaron o'toole
unveiled his party's plan to tackle
climate
change he promises to regulate large
industrial emitters
introduce zero emissions vehicle
mandates and
adopt a national clean fuel standard the
biggest shift though is that o'toole
agrees it is time to put a price on
carbon a policy
he has opposed until now david aiken
explains the vehicle just like
every other major party the
conservatives now agree
pricing carbon is key to cutting
greenhouse gas emissions
we recognize that the most efficient way
to reduce our emissions
is to use pricing mechanisms that's a
major
switch it's a big day the conservatives
have presented
a plan that can credibly meet canada's
current paris agreement target
to reduce emissions o'toole would
replace the liberal carbon tax and
rebate program
with a conservative low carbon savings
account
this plan scraps mr trudeau's carbon tax
this
is not a tax not a cent goes to ottawa
but consumers would still pay a carbon
price at the pump
a price which would earn a consumer
credit in that carbon savings account
then the consumer uses the credits in
that account
to buy items from a government approved
shopping list of
things that could lower emissions a bus
pass a bicycle
a home energy retrofit by contrast the
liberal carbon tax
rebate can be spent on anything the
conservatives
want to sell their police their carbon
pricing scheme for households as a
savings plan but it's not a savings plan
it's a tax
with restrictions on how households can
spend the money that they get back
but the big news here is that the leader
of the conservative party of canada
agrees that putting a price on carbon is
the way to cut
emissions that's a first now the big
question will that start to attract some
new voters to the conservatives
and perhaps a bigger question with
groups like the canadian taxpayers
federation
denouncing this as a straight-up carbon
tax
can aaron o'toole get conservatives to
get behind
his plan donna pretty interesting stuff
david aiken in ottawa thanks
still ahead blood clots after coveted
vaccines are extremely rare we hear from
a survivor
about her symptoms
you're watching global national
there is some important perspective
about the risk of developing blood clots
related to covid19
researchers at the university of oxford
report the risk of developing a rare
form of blood clotting is much greater
if you get covid19 than if you get a
vaccine to protect yourself from the
virus
the report says blood clots are reported
to occur in about five in
a million people after the first dose of
the oxford astrazeneca covid19 vaccine
it found the risks of the rare clots
from covid19 is about eight
times greater the study has not been
peer reviewed it says those numbers
could change because the data
of course is still coming in what is
certain is that this blood clotting
disorder is exceedingly rare
about 200 million doses of astrazeneca
have been given around the world and
about 200 cases of serious blood clots
have been reported
but it is wise to be aware of the
symptoms yesterday i spoke with a young
woman in the uk who just got out of the
hospital
lauren briggs is 32 years old mother of
two young children and lives in
flintshire wales
she had the astrazeneca shot on march
25th one of
more than 20 million people in the uk
who have been given that vaccine
by the end of march 79 people had
developed rare blood clots and
19 of them died
lauren is alive and well now but went
through a frightening experience
lauren thank you so much for talking
with us you started feeling ill
10 days after getting the astrazeneca
dose can you describe the symptoms and
what you noticed
that made you go to the hospital i
started with
a horrendous headache and i was really
breathless
um i had
like a i had a high temperature um
so worst case scenario for me personally
was that i thought i had covid which
i've not had before
um so i went that evening to get
a covid test which come back negative
um and that evening i noticed that i had
a horrendous pain in my left leg like in
my calf
so you were sent home given a blood
thinner and sent home
what happened next um i got a phone call
on the wednesday morning to go
into back to the hospital for a ct scan
on my lungs um i still
wasn't feeling well i was probably sat
there for about half an hour
until and then a member of staff came
over to me
because i was crying again because like
i was in a lot of pain and i was
obviously worried
and i got put into like a side ward into
a bed
and literally about five minutes later
two doctors and a consultant came over
to me
and then he said um basically
you have blood clots on your lungs and
we assume it's from the astrazeneca
vaccine
at this point i broke down in tears
because i was
really really worried um i'm only 32
i've got a four-year-old daughter and a
two-year-old son
and to be told that i had blood clots on
my lungs which
is deadly was scary and i did actually
ask him
am i gonna die and he said we need to
start
um treatment as soon as possible after
all these tests it come back
that um the blood clots
were in my leg if they they presume that
that's where they started
and then they traveled to my lungs
luckily there was no blood clots
on my brain you're still waiting to find
out if it's officially related to the
vaccine
but the doctors who you have seen so far
certainly suspect that on my uh
discharge notes it says vaccine induced
thrombosis and thrombocytopenia
every single doctor that i've seen has
said that they've never ever seen
this it's a kind of blood reaction
and clots and things in anyone you
should in theory be getting a second
astrazeneca dose
obviously you're not going to do that
right
no my um doctor advised me
not to get that because i would end up
in hospital again
it's not something that you ever think
that is going to happen to you
lauren thank you so much for sharing
your story with us and
glad you're feeling better and i hope it
improves much more thank you so much
thank you
and you can watch my full interview with
lauren on our website globalnews.ca
globalnational next the agonizing
anniversary in nova scotia as memories
of the mass killing
are still raw
it has been a year since a rural
community in nova scotia found itself in
the middle of a nightmare
a gunman disguised as an rcmp officer
killed 22 people
in a 13-hour rampage it began in the
tiny village of puerto pick
on april 18th and ended the next day
when the killer was finally found and
killed
by the police as a dreadful anniversary
approaches this weekend nova scotians
are still struggling
ross lord reports after a year of grief
and despair
some symbols of strength are emerging
for communities devastated by the mass
killings
like this steel monument created by a
man whose stepson
corey ellison was murdered along with 21
others
when i say in the poem you know you're
still in a part of our heart and
our mind you know we can go back to that
but we still have to live
and go on nearby there's a series of
memorial markers
honoring the victims and intended to
ease the pain of a murder spree too
horrific to ever be understood
i have a good friend who lost a very
close family member
and she's had a hard year it's senseless
senseless there's no re rhyme or reason
why somebody would
do that is in this day and age
in nova scotia healing collectively is
complicated
especially with pandemic restrictions
just ask those whose job it is to help
like pastor stephen adams those things
are really important and it's that
that the the ability to be able to
connect with other people
and it's been made a lot harder pastor
adams
says there's no shortage of goodwill i
know there are a lot of people
that care and a lot of people that want
to help and that's a good thing that's
always a good thing
for victims families including
schoolteacher lisa mccauley's sister
april 18th and 19th mark a dreaded first
anniversary it's agonizing
those dates trigger horrific memories we
are reliving the immediate pain that we
felt
jenny kirstad says therapy has helped
her cope but there are questions
about how the nova scotia mental health
system has responded in rural
communities
that were devastated by the mass
killings there's a fragmentation
i guess i would say it's fragmented and
that's really had implications i think
on the community and it will
moving forward as well serena lewis
lives in great village next to porter
pick
she just finished the term as nova
scotia's grief and bereavement
coordinator
she suggests traumatized communities
need a more concerted effort
but this is a specialized team of people
that are going to come to the
communities
meet people where they're at and try to
build this foundationally
from the ground up the need for support
is far from over
mental health counselors say for some
people the after effects of extreme
trauma can become even worse
in the second year there are new stop
gaps like nova scotia psychologists
offering three free sessions per person
to those
most affected i've received about a
dozen calls so far they're people who
didn't reach out originally
because they thought they were okay even
a year later these are early days
in the aftermath of something so hideous
and so shocking
ross laura global news debert nova
scotia
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is art rossen alberta
just east of edmonton thanks for
watching robin gill will be at the
anchor desk tomorrow and i'll see you on
saturday for the new reality
take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Applause]
you